there was children coming to Twitter and  they ignored them well that is  absolutely just just let's boil your  blood right now let's contextualize this  it's not like you know what what was the  last episode of Seinfeld they the Good  Samaritan law they get arrested it  wasn't like someone was standing on the  side of the road they saw someone  getting kidnapped and went I'm not  getting involved no no no this was  they're driving the car and they they  get an Uber and they pick someone up  who's like grabbing a woman off the  street and throwing them in the car and  like hey man I'm just a driver don't  mind me  that's what it was Twitter was  facilitating this Twitter had created a  platform allowing these people to do  these things to post these things they  were the vehicle by which this stuff was  delivered and they had an obligation to  say we can't have that illegal activity  in our bus so they did nothing